no vabbè amo non puoi capire che serata pazzesca
eh sì perché dopo la discoteca siamo andati a questo after e poi siamo andati a far
colazione perché ti pare che non
mangiavo che stavo morendo di fame
domani ti giuro ti racconto tutto adesso
voglio soltanto tipo morire nel letto
complimenti eh brava brava ti sembra
questa l'ora di tornare 7.48 del mattino
ma tu sei pazza cosa sei una vagabonda
ma lo sai che non ho chiuso occhio tutta
la notte perché ero in pensiero guarda
io te lo dico quando muoio poi fai
quello che vuoi ma finché vivi sotto
questo tetto tu fai quello che ti dico
io e non tornare mai piú a quest'ora hai
capito dove diavolo sono le avevo
lasciate qua sicuro mi saranno cadute
dove sono dove sono mamma hai visto le
mie cuffie son sparite non le trovo più
sto cercando dappertutto ma sono lá le vedo con i miei occhi
lí sopra il tavolo
sei cieca ti devo portare da un
oculista ma non è possibile non c'erano
non trovi mai niente non sai cercare
amore mio dimmi solo una cosa chi chi è stato a ridurti così perché piangi così ti avranno
sicuramente fatto qualcosa
adesso tu mi racconti tutto perché io lo
vado a prendere con le mie mani la mia bambina non si toccaamore mio non piangere
si buonasera volevo ordinare una pizza d'asporto allora si doppia mozzarella funghi prosciutto e olive
e anche friarielli e anche würstel
no no volevo anche un cheeseburger se
possibile e una birra
no no quella da 66 sì sì sì tutto per me
si abito in via si buonasera volevo
ordinare una pizza d'asporto
mi chiamo marina via via quel telefono
via eh hai la professionista della pizza
in casa e la vai a prendere d'asporto
mamma mia faccio finta di non aver
sentito cosa vuoi dentro la pizza ti
metto tutto prosciutto mozzarella di
bufala e non parmigiano parmigiana
melanzane fritte peperoni quello che
vuoi basta che metti giù quel telefono
io invece sto guardando una serie tv
fighissima che è uscita da poco amo cioè
te la consiglio é bellissima ti giuro cioè
non riesco a smettere no ma é proprio  quelle
sai che ti prendono
no amo sto guardando una serie tv nuova
fighissima te la consiglio adesso ti
scrivo il titolo perché non me lo
ricordo
stavo guardando la serie tv cosa stai
facendo
senti ascolta le sette lo sai é l'orario
della mia telenovela quindi io adesso mi metto
qui me la guardo anche perché è stato
fernando io devo scoprirlo perché secondo me
é stato lui che non me la conta tanto
giusta ma no resta qua con me
che ti piace se guardi una puntata poi ti prende senti la sigla che bella
ma questa maglia era bianca ed è diventata minuscola
ma cosa come è possibile una volta a 40 gradi
mamma carico la lavatrice ferma lì te
l'ho detto mille volte marina ma guarda
stavi lavando i colorati con i bianchi
con i i delicati li devi fare a parte in acqua
fredda in acqua fredda te l'ho detto mille
volte i colorati vai guarda veramente vai
via faccio io